some people think that the time is right
for the solar revolution that one day
solar power will replace oil and we'll
all live in a world that's clean and
renewable well not so fast
I believe in solar power however there
are problems that we have to face and
one of them is low efficiency the other
one is lack of a storage facility like a
battery that's the weak link we simply
don't have the efficiency of solar cells
necessary to make it economical and
competitive today and the ability to
store the energy for long periods of
time when the Sun is dark when there are
clouds and your subtle solar panels
don't work so my point of view is this I
think in the coming decade as oil prices
start to rise and as the pot the cost of
wind and solar and renewables start to
drop the two curves will probably cross
in maybe 10 years so in 10 years it'll
be the marketplace which then begins to
drive the whole thing forward because of
the dropping cost of solar cells and
efficients rising efficiency and the
rising price of oil now why do I believe
the oil prices will rise because of
something called Hubbert's peak Hubbert
was a shale oil engineer way back in the
1960s who predicted that we would hit
the halfway point for the production of
oil in the United States and after that
the bell-shaped curve would curve the
other way and we would become a net
importer of oil well people laughed at
him because they said that well wait a
minute we have Alaska we have Texas we
have lots of oil fields and so we're not
going to hit the 50% point America will
always export oil well wrong Humbert hit
it right on the nose
to within the Year at which a US oil
supplies peaked and then it went to the
other side of the bell-shaped curve
that's called Hubbert's peak when we hit
the 50% point now we know the Hubbert
was right and the next big question is
are we hitting harbor
speak for world oil production that is
the $64,000 question many people that
I've talked to senior oil analysts
energy analysts say that we are either
at Hubbert's peak or within 10 years of
hitting Hubbert's peak now some people
say well that's stupid we discovered new
oil deposits all the time look at Canada
we have tar sands of Canada right wrong
it turns out that we will always have
oil we will never run out of oil
except oil we become more expensive as
we go down the other side of Hubbert's
peak we would have to discover a new
Saudi Arabia every five to ten years in
order for this curve to simply go on
forever that's not going to happen I
don't care how many tar sands you're
talking about in Canada you're not going
to create a new Saudi Arabia which
produces very clean very cheap oil oil
that is prized by the oil companies
because it is relatively less polluting
and has tremendous amounts of profits
associated with it so we do know the oil
prices will fluctuate because of
politics but on average it'll start to
rise because we will be hitting
Hubbert's peak meanwhile solar powers
can become cheaper and in ten years or
so the two curves could actually cross
and in 20 years a new game-changer
arrives and that is fusion power the
Europeans are bidding the store on the
ITER fusion reactor to be built outside
Kardash France in southern France and if
we have the power of the Sun on the
earth then seawater could drive all our
machines so if this scenario plays out
as I predict it means that global
warming could actually be a problem only
for the next several decades as we enter
the solar era and the fusion era the
problem is we have already lofted so
much carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
and we will continue to do so for
decades to come that
even before we enter the solar age and
the fusion age we will have so much
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere that we
will really screw up the weather but on
a long-term basis I think that solar
energy and fusion power will be the
solution the ultimate solution for the
greenhouse problem